les rappeler ces chiffres cette guerre
jette chaque jour sur les routes des
milliers de civils certains partent se
mettre à l'abri à l'ouest dans la région
de lviv par exemple d'autres fonds choix
de quitter l'ukraine 2 million d'hommes
de femmes et d'enfants ont ainsi fui
pays ce dernier chiffre a été publié à
part le haut commissariat des nations
unies pour les réfugiés les états
voisins accueillent ces populations et
ce chiffre pourrait être encore plus
important dans les prochains jours
bonjour à vous car la ml qui vous est
coordinatrice d'urgence de médecins sans
frontières vous êtes à chisinau en
moldavie merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de france24 merci de
prendre le temps de nous parler
aujourd'hui la plus grande crise
humanitaire sur le continent depuis de
nombreuses années c'est le constat fait
par le commissaire européen à l'aide
humanitaire est ce que c'est aussi votre
crainte vous msf
d'écouté mis en invoquant notamment sur
le plan médical pour regard mais
l'ensemble des besoins dans leur
globalité nous allons j'aime beaucoup
c'est la rupture de chaîne
d'approvisionnement puisqu'en fait bonne
lan les blessés direct de la guerre on
risque d'avoir à l'impact en terme de
fonds publics assez désastreux que
certains produisent un entraînement ne
sont plus disponibles sont des gens près
rupture on pense à l'écologie à des
valises mais aussi à des traces minimes
qu'ils peuvent à à plus ou moins long
terme avoir un impact très durable pour
les populations dont ils vous faisiez
état dans les colonnes de presse écrite
dont confrères de manque d'insuline ou
d'hémodialyse ce sont aussi ces
personnes là qui risque d'être des
victimes de cette guerre sans forcément
malheureusement périr sous les bons
mètres en manque de médicaments pour des
maladies chroniques c'est aussi un
risque
c'est vraiment un des enjeux là d'une
barmaid la d17 guerre
de la guerre mais la question des enjeux
de maladies chroniques reste pour nous
aussi une des priorités et en aidant
viable carl hamel qu'il ya environ je
crois 150 personnes c'est le staff de
dsf en ukraine quels retours vont vos
équipes sur le terrain écouter
aujourd'hui les à pouvoir trouver un
espace 2 espace de travail entre les
zones qui sont malheureux assez
compliqué taxi par le niveau de sécurité
dans sécurité qui est reine et il la
possibilité d'intervenir on travaille
également sur l'ensemble des pays
d'accueil donc les pays frontaliers
notamment en pologne en moldavie où je
me trouve aujourd'hui on voit la main
des modes de santé c'est le long du
couloir d'attentes ousmaïl important on
a aussi ce sera ça c'est des
compensations chronique et qui pourrait
aussi potentiellement quand on parle
foot de la moldavie pouvoir être à
potentiel couloir d'évacuation des
personnes qui seraient bloqués notamment
aux dessins dont on revient récemment et
comment est ce que vous identifier les
zones où il faut intervenir en urgence
le je pense que voilà c'est tout un
homme juste balance à trouver entre le
besoin médical grandissant et notre
capacité à pouvoir accéder à ces zones
là il y avait
quand même il ya des pénuries que vous
évoquez l'instant de certains
traitements ce qui manque le plus c'est
aussi la nourriture en fait on a des
populations privées dodo courant d'eau
potable tout simplement contrainte de
boire parfois l'eau de pluie privés
d'électricité privé de nourriture
certains magasins certains d'entre eux
ont été bombardées par par les forces
russes c'est ce qui revient d'abord en
en priorité c'est ce manque de denrées
je voudrais dire plutôt basique en fait
première nécessité tout à fait à prix
d'or la distinction entre des villes qui
sont dans des situations dramatiques de
sièges et voilà les quelques lesquels en
premier lieu
j'ai pas pu de nouveau mais voilà on
connait tous les villes qui sont dans
des situations les plus compliquées que
s'assoyait mar diop hall ou car kim qui
vivent des situations vraiment extrêmes
et des villes comme des saints qui se
prépare aujourd'hui à un siège mais
néanmoins ce qu'on peut constater
aujourd'hui dans ces villes là même au
dessin qui est pas encore aujourd'hui
sous le feu des bombes il y avoit là
beaucoup moins de denrées dans le sud
dans les supermarchés les magasins sont
fermés il ya peu de gens là cela semble
déjà avoir été en partie désertes et
même si les équipes soignantes sont
toujours là est prête à répondre
il ya cette fois de préparation de
sièges qu'on peut percevoir dans la
troisième de libye et comment est-ce que
fonctionnent les hôpitaux on nous parle
justement grâce aux hérésies bouffon vos
équipes
alors bon pour avoir le même état au
dessin effectivement il ya eu une
réorganisation des équipements on peut
même le comparer d'une certaine manière
à ce qu'on a pu vivre pendant la
dernière pandémie qui nous dit quoi il
ya eu la déprogrammation les équipes
seront organisés ont essayé de voilà de
s'adapter de se préparer à ce qu'on
appelle des plans d'afflux massif ou de
blessés mais aussi à d'autres d'autres
bateaux logique qui hérisse prend un peu
de venir remplir les urgences qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait acheminer en urgence
quels sont les laits produits dont vous
avez besoin grande urgence
écoutez ça dépend voilà les hôpitaux
dans le rang sans fond des demandes
d'appui enfin si l idée c'est aussi
d'avoir des stocks de réserve pour
pouvoir faire face à des situations
auxquelles ils seraient coupés de toute
possibilité d'approvisionnement donc on
est sur l'ensemble des besoins que
nécessite un soin de santé
merci beaucoup carla melki